dane dunning on the mount for the
rangers tonight 18 starts this year the
era a little over four
he rips this ball out into right field
and that one will one hop the fence
calhoun is gonna try and stretch it for
two the throw from gallow
got him
and calhoun did what so many have tried
and so few have done well and that is
run on joey another outfield assist from
the rangers right fielder all right so
dunning two quick outs gets eduardo
escobar now
ground ball and that one
just over the mound and handled cleanly
by kinder philippa 12 pitch first inning
for dane dunning the right-hander taylor
widener his third start since his second
stay on the engine list after that nanky
groin problem well there you see his
record seven games 1-0 with a 3.55
back-to-back watts so a little bout of
wildness here for widener here is joey
gallo full count three and two
well there it is it's one of the three
true outcomes to walk a strikeout or a
homer and that's a big out number two
for taylor widener and here comes andy
ibani is riding a six-game hitting
streak
swinging in a fly ball to right going
back calhoun backpedaling makes the
catch shy of the track and the inning is
over a couple of walks but widener works
through the heart of the texas order so
now brock holt here's the 1-1
and that one is lying to left and that's
a base hit falls in cleveland peralta
two-out single for holt that's the first
ranger hit in this scoreless game full
count now on white swing and a miss got
him to chase a fastball up and out of
the strike zone and the inning is over
two out single a man left we've played
two no score d-backs in texas andrew
young leads off for the d-max at the top
of the third dunning's one-two
and a swing and a miss he gets young to
chase and that's his first strikeout of
the night then it brings up nick ahmed
nick trying to bun his way on brockholtz
was back at third and nick's aboard nice
heads-up play by nick ahmed brock bolt
did the best he could a nice bare hand
play right there but it's a one-ounce
single and here comes the left-handed
hitting dalton varsho
as this pitch is down and in but the
runner takes off then stops it now heim
bluffs the throw to second throws behind
the runner at first and ahmed is picked
off by ahmed i i guess that was supposed
to be a delayed steal attempt but then
he put on the brakes and he was dead
between first and second time bluff the
throw to second but was able to fire in
behind him and varsho takes the walk
paul calhoun belted a ball into the
right field corner to lead off the ball
game
gets this one deep to left center field
cole calhoun reaches the wall and this
time he'll have a double far show coming
around third no throw when the
diamondbacks have the lead cole calhoun
two for two he drilled that to deep left
center field a nice piece of hitting got
one up in the zone there and just rode
it out to left center field runners at
the corners nobody out one-nothing
d-batch
got it in there and popped it up
out number one oh for the second time in
three innings taylor widener will face
joey gallo with two runners on base
calo got under
it more time for escobar taylor widener
stranded two in the first can he do it
again in the third it's going to be up
to andy abanez now
and that's ball four and now they're
loaded for david dahl the rangers are
the only major league team without a
grand slam this year the one-two to doll
swing and a miss and a high fastball and
widener gets out of the jam
texas leaves them loaded we've played
three d-backs one texas nothing walker
aboard for the diamondbacks a one-ounce
single ahead of his drupal cabrera
cabrera down the line and walker's on
the move
richton walker will stop at third as
drobo the former ranger is back in town
with a one out double and the
diamondbacks are set up again here
runners at second and third with one out
now for david peralta
david sends it to right right at joey
gallo
here comes walker
cabrera is hung up walker's home
as durable on the move
look out watch that hammy and walker
comes across before the out is recorded
jonah heim the catcher leads it off for
the rangers 1-1 heim swings and clubs
one to deep right field calhoun going
back near the fence leaps and he's got
it
cole calhoun makes a leaping grab into
the fence in right field to take away
extra bases from jonah heim one out real
nice play by cole calhoun who's already
won one gold glove cole calhoun goes up
to the base of the wall jumps up and
makes an outstanding grab and its base
is full again here in the fourth alone
has reached twice tonight
this ball in the air deep out to left
field that could be trouble it bounces
up over the roll and into the bullpen
that is a book rule double two runs
score connor falefa will have to hold
third base but a huge hit
by nathaniel lowe he's tied the game at
two in the fourth inning and it will
bring gallow up now with two out and
this ball pounded deep out to center
field that one taking smith back it's
gone
25th of the year for gallow great to
have him back and it's 5-2 rangers
big home run and a big spot for joey
gallo once again so widener again just
playing with fire all game long is
finally burnt by low and gallow so a
lead off single for young and now ahmed
who had a bunch single his first time up
there's a double play ball right to
counter for effort to emanyas to low
they turn it easily 6-4-3 and the bases
are clear with two outs here in the
fifth speaking of connor philippa varso
hits one right at him a hard skimmer and
izzy throws him out
so a very quick shutdown inning for dean
dunning so walker does what his name
suggests and that brings up cabrera
this one
is right in there strike three called
right
at the bottom of the zone and cabrera
down looking third strikeout of the
night and that will do it six and a
third for dunning joe barlow first man
up out of the bullpen 2-2 pitch here is
in there for a called third strike a
late strike call by manny gonzalez a
very delayed call we've got two men out
here in the top half of the seventh
swinging a miss he struck him out got
him with a slider so barlow fans the two
batters that he faces here to wrap up
the top half of the seven so marshall at
second two outs now for pavon smith he's
over three
punches it through the gap marshall
coming around third rbi for paving smith
then it's a 5-3 ball game a run is in
two on and two out down two in the
eighth walker has singled scored and
walked
walker drops it into right center
here comes pavon smith and it's a
one-run ball game well suddenly a
one-run game and the diamondbacks have
escobar at third base christian walker
at first the veterans drubal cabrera
will be due
the rangers answer by bringing dewali
rodriguez out of the bullpen here
and that one in the air right field
gallow
ranging back still going back and he
makes the catch
that ends the inning and the
diamondbacks lead that time run at third
bait looking forward to a positive
finish in this one ian kennedy out there
looking for the save
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
peralta
one away next up andrew young amazing
with kennedy strikes out young
back-to-back strikeouts two away the
reigns are an out away from putting the
12-game losing streak behind them
and that's in the air
should be the final out gallow is in for
it
and fittingly gallow catches the final
out of this one of the rangers putting
into that losing skid with a 5-4 win
over the diamondbacks